have an unusual story to tell you
tonight in our media focus it seems the
mainstream outlets are actually giving
credit to a top republican who is often
a target of fierce criticism
fox news media analyst and host of fox's
media buzz howard kurtz tells us
who it is and what has changed
100 of our focus is on
stopping this new administration
mitch mcconnell has endured years of bad
press as the democrats dastardly demon
and famously vowed to make barack obama
a one-term president
really why don't you get a drink with
mitch mcconnell
the senate republican leader who denied
even a hearing to obama's supreme court
pick merrick garland
has embraced a negative nickname i am
indeed
the grim reaper when it comes to the
socialist agenda but that has abruptly
changed since the hard-nosed technician
agreed to work with the white house
on a bipartisan infrastructure bill
despite plenty of media skepticism
is mcconnell really going to give biden
a win
but the popular compromise is moving
forward prompting politico to declare
pigs fly mcconnell is also drawing
credit from cnn and others
for spending campaign funds to promote
covet vaccines on 100 kentucky radio
stations
is anybody out there willing to listen
get vaccinated i'm going to use a
sentence here that is not uttered very
often on msnbc airways
good for mitch mcconnell and president
biden gave his adversary
a shout out i have to compliment
republican senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell
he had made it politically a mcconnell
spokesman says of the negative narrative
the media always lean left
and don't like the fact that he worked
with donald trump but the journalistic
reassessment of mcconnell
is rooted in the way he broke with the
former president after january 6
and said trump bears moral
responsibility for the capital riot when
mcconnell said he'd vote for the
infrastructure bill
trump attacked him for quote weak
leadership mcconnell who stays off the
sunday shows has never much cared about
being roasted and ridiculed
by elite commentators and op-ed warriors
when i asked the senator
is enjoying this brief burst of applause
his spokesman told me
i don't think it affects him one way or
another mike howie kurtz thanks a lot
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else